hello everyone and welcome to round five
well rather Game five of the 1971 semi
final candidates match between Bobby
Fischer and bent Larsen as you've seen
in the previous game Fischer born yet
again in a beautiful Kings Indian game
if you haven't seen it there will be a
link in the description below so feel
free to check it out now the result is
currently in this match a four to zero
for Fisher and Larsen really what he
doesn't want to do he doesn't want to
take mark the amount of steps and ended
the match six to zero so he he can still
bounce back but it will be I mean no one
can even remember when was the last time
Bobby Fischer lost the game it was some
some time during the 1971 with America
intra zonal tournament but that being
said we said that after Game four the
match was postponed and as Larsen
started feeling ill now some people
thought that he started feeling ill
because he was simply crushed by four to
zero result others said that it was the
cause of the what's it called a altitude
sickness I've also found some people
call it elevation sickness what altitude
sickness is basically your body reacts
the lower oxygen pressure at the higher
altitudes and I even found a YouTube
video a video on YouTube about how to
how to get your body ready for when you
visit it then we're Colorado it says
that altitude sickness will mostly go
away after like 24 hours or maybe a day
and a half and then you're ready to go
climbing but you know if it doesn't you
should definitely seek out some help and
it's as this is already supposed to be
game five they already played four games
it's hard to say if if Larson really was
suffering from altitude sickness then
the sickness would have already kicked
in during Game one and it seems he would
was playing all of the games while
suffering with altitude sickness so it's
very hard to say I haven't found was
this really the case because then the
match simply continued and nothing
nothing was said about this anyway
anymore but a lot of you have mentioned
this in the comments so thank you for
that thank you for increasing my vast
knowledge
so that being said let's check out the
game again Fischer has the white pieces
and again he opens with efore before I
forget we do have a nice photo of this
match sorry about that
there it is the one we've already seen
but this is a photo challenge as it's
been a very long time since we had one
who can you recognize amongst all all
these people here and extra points if
you can name the event during which this
was taken and also which game was it so
there we have it best of luck to
everyone now let's check out the game
like we said official opens with E for
of course now we have C 5 by Larson
Knight to f3 d6 d4 this is silly defense
is on the board C captors Knight
captures Knight to f6 Knight to c3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 the swords
in attack by Fisher as he always goes
for it we have e 6th transposing into
the shredding and Bishop to b3 and now
Bishop to e7 I will have Bishop to e3
castles and this is a the exact same
order of moves that was played in game 3
in the match official versus Larsen we
have castles Bishop to d7 and f4 and
this is the exact same position that was
on the board during the game 3 and if
you remember during Game three Larsen
played a6 to which official replied f5
and then only after Larsen played this
Queen to see it move the game was
already lost you can remember that
character Sammy 6 was played captures
captures captures and then Fischer found
this a remarkable Knight to a4 move
which basically ends the game there's no
defense against Knight to b6 which was
come against as an attack against the
Queen and the rook and also the Queen
will no longer be able to protect the e6
pawn so this was a very swift victory in
round 3 in game 3 so if you haven't seen
that I'll link to all of the games will
be in the description below you know you
should definitely check it out those are
some wonderful games do do feel free to
expand your vast knowledge as well so
here after f4 larson doesn't bother
himself with this a6 move he finds an
improvement Queen to see it immediately
preventing f5 and here I think after
already being down four points in the
match
this next move is not the the the
greatest move in the position but III
think Fischer heater had it prepared and
just waited for for a Larsson to fall
for it or he simply played it the crush
you know I really crush Larsson as he
was already feeling really bad about how
the whole mismatch was going here
Fischer pushed f5 nonetheless so Larsson
prepared this as an improvement on Game
three at the prevent f5 and Fischer now
plays it and now I mean it's fairly
obvious that it's a pawn sacrifice but
what does Fischer gain from it nothing
much really
Larsson plays Knight captures on d4 ok
bushel captures we have eight captors on
f5 and now Queen to d3 Fischer threatens
to win back the pawn so we have F
captures on e4 Larsson accepts the pawn
and Knight captures on e4 Knight
captures on e4 and now Queen captures on
e4 okay Bishop to e6 offering to trade
bishops Bishop captures and F captors
would only have two black you would now
have a very nice pawn chain here in the
center you can exchange rooks and all
would be well for black here
so instead Fischer goes rook to f3 and
it's a very nice active position for
white regardless of being down upon you
can see that the bishops are slicing all
the way against the black king the Queen
is also very nice to place the rook is
coming to be doubled on it on the F file
this row can come to g3 h3 well not h3
at the moment but it's a very active
position for white and black still has
to develop the rooks so we have Queen to
c6 here
Larsson offers a trade of Queens if if
you go for the immediate exchange you
know as you are up a pawn you might
think okay I might exchange a piece so
you know this will only improve my
position but you always have to worry
about this rook to g3 idea a nice
in-between move the dissolution cook as
some of you have mentioned that you
enjoy when I when I use the the Deutsch
word or the German word so f6 you have
to block this rook a press on g7 and
only then will capture some b3 and here
even without being down down upon
White's position would be
excellence as mike has a really messed
up bone structure this bishop is
basically a pawn here so white would
have all the compensation necessary so
here instead first Queen to c6 Larson
offers a trade of Queens and we have
rook 81 you can see even being down upon
Fisher doesn't mind trading Queen's
Queen captures only four rook captures
on e4 and now d5 and okay we have rook
to g3 offering this rock on e4 but of
course you cannot accept this if you
accept pawn captures on e4 you get rook
captures and g7 with check only movies
came to h8 and now you can do pretty
much whatever you want
rook captures on f7 with check you have
to block it or whatever you whatever you
do basically will result in checkmate
for example if you go to g8 King g8
you're gonna get Ruby Jade sure King
moves rook captures rook has to block
simply Bishop captures King goes here
Bishop captures King goes here rook
captures ends now there's really no
defense here whatever you play you will
be checkmated as the bishops are
creating a nice wall here but okay there
are a lot more ways this can go a lot
more variations that can be played out
but all of them lead to the checkmate so
g6 first by Larson and here we have
Bishop captures on d5 here Fischer wins
back Larson's extra pawn and it can it's
pretty much a draw here after Bishop
captures rook captures we enter this
endgame where white has a three-to-two
advantage on the Queen side but two
rooks each opposite colored bishops most
likely a drone and game even I mean
regardless of what can happen it's it's
a draw position
so after this Bishop to b5 Larson a draw
really doesn't do much for him so he
goes the Bishop to d6 he attacks
Fischer's Rokon g3 and here like I said
the Larson could have gone for a draw
here and probably many more times during
this game but he has the wind start
winning some at least some of the games
in the match
so Bishop to d6 attacking the rook on g3
and here Fischer goes rook captures on
e6 so Fischer is no longer interested in
a draw
as larson prolongs the game now Fisher
wants to win this we have bushel
captures on g3 you cannot capture here
because after Bishop captures on e6 the
king has really nowhere to go you have
to block and then rook to f3 you attack
the rook here after rook blocks you can
simply grab a pawn and then only after
this exchange everything on f7 and then
you would enjoy two extra points and win
this game easily so after rook to e6 we
have Bishop captures in g3 and then now
comes rook to e7 of course you cannot
capture the bishop and allow F captures
96 so rook to e7 and now you can see
that Larsen's Bishop is under attack and
also the b7 point is under attack so you
have to save the piece Bishop d6 rook
captures on b7 and now rook to c8
offering the a 7 point but Larsson would
enjoy grabbing the c2 point of course
Fischer will have none of this he pushes
c4 we have a 5 and rook to a7 and here
we have a position where fisheries up a
pawn and he does have this excellent
centralized bishop repair but all in all
it's very unlikely that you could
actually move it will be hard to defend
against this this pawn chain on the
Queen side but everyone was pretty sure
that Larson could do it but even even in
this position Larson is still pushing
for a win
Bishop to c7 he protects the f5 pawn and
now we have g3 you know reducing the
mobility of the bishop preparing you
know so the King can come into the game
rook F to e 8 and now King to f1 not
allowing the rook to come crashing down
on the first rank rook to e7
we have Bishop to f6 rook to e3 and
Bishop back to c3 so Fisher doesn't
really have any any actual plan he just
I'm sure he would not mind a draw here
after so many wins but Larson still
pushes for the win and he tries to find
a way how to do something here h5 was
played in the now rook to h6 with some
nasty threats like rook captures and g6
as the f7 pawn is pinned and now comes
Bishop to e5 a very interesting move by
Larson as now rook captures and g6 with
check
wouldn't do all that much simply King h7
now your rook is under attacked after we
moved the rugged and Bishop characters
and c3 comes B captures on c3 and now
after rook comes to b8 you can see that
now it's the white king that's actually
in a lot of danger here and the black
would be better here
so after Bishop to e5 we'll have Bishop
to d2 if ever finds a beautiful way to
attract the Larsson's rook as now after
playing Bishop to e5 the rook can no
longer go back we have ripped the d3
attacking the bishop and now King to e2
attacking the rook the rook
only Square for the rook is d4 rook to
d4 what's played and now comes the bush
of the c3 and now the rook no longer has
any squares a froggie g4 then the bishop
on e5 would be hanging so Roxy captures
and c4 was played Bishop captures and
now rook captures on c4 you don't want
to capture here because rook check would
pick up after he moves would pick up the
bishop I you would still have a better
position because of the two-to-one
advantage on the Queen side but you
would still have to work for a meal so
after rook c4 King to b3 attacking the
rook now rook moves and now comes rook
captures on a5 rook captures and Bishop
captures and Bishop captures and b2 so
what's happened here basically official
reduced this entire game into 3 points
against the three pawns end game with
the same colored bishops but this end
game is completely winning from white so
we can also use it as a nice example of
how to win in games when you have the
outside passed pawn so when I saw this
position okay a4 was played then comes
King to a faithful our son of course
wants to bring his King into the game
here I thought okay Bishop to b6 seems
like a very nice idea
the bishop guards all the dark squares
you know this pawn has to step on until
promoted to a queen but this would
actually be a much longer way of
capitalizing on your advantage because
here if you just start pushing the pawn
the King would be able to be able to
stop the pawn and then once again you
would still have to work for your meal
it's still much better for white and you
would most likely win this but you know
it would be it would take much longer
so here official plays the absolute best
move Bishop to c3 he offers the exchange
of bishops
most likely the best thing to do here
would be to avoid the trade but even if
you avoid the trade white would simply
push the pawn a five after the bishop
stops it simply attacking the bishop
bishop goes back offer a trade of
Bishops if you move back simply a six a
seven and black would have to give up
the bishop ends now the position is
easily winning for white so Larson tries
to capture we have Bishop captures King
captures and King to e7 King the d4 was
played and now we have a classic
situation where black has to deal with
the pawn on the Queen side because
Fischer can simply push it the victory
and while the black king is busy with
the pass pawn the outside pass pawn
under Queen side pressure once it will
simply gobble up all of the pawns on the
King side and easily win the game so
King the d6 was played we have a 5 f6 we
have a 6 King to c6 a7 King to b7 King
to d5 we have h4 and King to e6 and it
was in this position that bent Larsen
resigned to the game and now we have
five to zero result in this match for
Bobby Fischer what if you resign well
there's not that much to do here
whatever black plays white will simply
gobble up all of the pawns and black
will simply not be in time to prevent
white from promoting the pawn and black
white will simply create a wall against
the black King here and simply push his
nice past Jeep on to victory
so after this King to his six move been
Flores and resigned the game and yet
another great victory for Bobby Fischer
I'm sure Larson definitely prepared for
this variation as he well he had a
terrible loss in Game three after that
a6 Queen to c8 idea and now he prepared
Quinta CA to move prior to a6 and Fisher
who moves F plays a5 nonetheless and
again it's like it's as if he just
laughed at Larsen's face but I mean
Fischer was pretty much satisfied with a
draw in this game and Larson had to push
for a win and the end result was another
victory for Bobby Fischer
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it and that you're enjoying the coverage
of the Bobby Fischer
series so far the links to all of the
games we've covered will be in the
description below also we are more than
welcome to check out the match with
March tomorrow with vehement and also
the entire path upon America inter-zonal
tournament I would like to thank Rae
Fowler Joseph Corporation in Elliott
court a douche a neon chick and Bethany
low for a contribution to my channel
think a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see soon
most likely with game 6 of the map of
the 1971 semi final candidates match
between Bobby Fischer and bent Larsen
thank you all and I'll see you soon